the American scientist who oversaw the
creation of the first atomic bomb and
never regretted dropping it on Hiroshima
Japan but James Conant was afraid of a
nuclear standoff similar to the one
brewing today between the United States
and North Korea now Conan's
granddaughter is writing about his life
and career man of the hour is published
by Simon & Schuster division of CBS Tony
Tecopa
spoke to the author about her
grandfather's warnings Tony good morning
good morning warnings indeed Conant was
in charge of bringing America into the
nuclear age but his granddaughter
best-selling author and historian
Jeanette Conant says his efforts to
control the weapons were ignored and now
the all-out nuclear conflict he worried
about could be close at hand this was
his nightmare scenario that we would
have this enormous arms race and that it
would just increase sort of unabated and
that we would inevitably find ourselves
as he said like two gunmen with itchy
trigger fingers Jeannette Conan's
grandfather James B conet wasn't the
kind of person given to fear or
exaggeration and yet my grandfather was
really so terrified of a nuclear
conflict I think the idea that mutually
assured destruction would have held for
almost 70 years
would have surprised him in the late 30s
Conant was a brilliant chemist a veteran
of poison gas production during World
War one and a successful president of
Harvard University but his life changed
course after Albert Einstein warned the
White House about the potential for
extremely powerful bombs
that triggered a desperate race to build
a nuclear weapon before Hitler's Germany
and the task of winning fell to Conan
and a secret team of scientists he was
the supervisor of everything that
happened in terms of the bombs
development what happened in the summer
of 1945 was the first open air test of a
nuclear weapon a blast so shocking that
Conan from a nearby bunker was sure the
team had miscalculated and he thought in
that moment the world is over he did
terrifying absolutely terrifying just
three weeks later her Oshima and then
Nagasaki still the only wartime use of a
nuclear weapon
we have spent more than two billion
dollars on the greatest scientific
gamble in history and we have won
hundreds of thousands died in the blasts
and their aftermath people always ask me
you know did they feel guilty they
really felt that they had done the right
thing in building the bomb it did
shorten the war it did save lives and
yet conet and his colleagues warned of
the need to control the bomb by sharing
the science and striking a global deal
to curtail production but the scientists
were overruled and today do you feel
safer or less safe
oh we're less safe we have this massive
destructive force out there and
ultimately he said we have no sane
option but for the international
community to come together and try and
find a way to control these weapons
there hasn't been a mushroom cloud seen
live in seven decades
don't tempt fate that's what my
grandfather would say these are not
weapons to play with we must find a more
sane way backward will we I hope and
pray this year's Nobel Peace Prize went
to an organization hoping to ban nuclear
weapons and last summer the United
Nations advanced the very first treaty
to do so the United States however
boycotted the talks saying the timing is
not right to lay down new
clear arms I cannot get over the image
of her grandfather in a bunker in the
desert watching the very first nuclear
explosion and not being sure they've
done the math right they don't know that
the explosion is ever going to end
don't tempt fate very very important
words there Tony thank you